(gentle music)
Even the ancient Egyptians
knew the importance of the perfect brow.
They wore them dark, arched and elongated.
But they'd shave them off when their cat died
as a sign of mourning.
RIP Kitty. (cat meows)
In ancient Greece and Rome, the unibrow was the way to go.
It's symbolized intelligence and was worn
by the most notoriously beautiful women.
Fast forward to the 20th century
and every decade brings us a slight shift in brow beauty.
The twenties brought the first
commercially made makeup products,
which allowed women to emulate
their favorite silent movie stars,
while the forties and fifties saw a thicker brow
for a softer look.
The seventies and eighties saw big hair,
big fashion and big natural brows.
And then the nineties and two thousands
brought us back to thinly plucked, highly arched
and looking good.
Today a bold brow is the epitome of fashion,
but don't worry, because if history tells us anything,
this story of the eyebrow is ever changing.
(loud clapping)
Mm, some familiar faces
in that one.
Okay, it's true, I was a skinny brow queen in the nineties,
and then I rocked a lot of different looks.
And thankfully my brows have grown back
and I can show you all some amazing tools
to perfect your brow grain.
Okay, Anastasia of Beverly Hills
has been the brow boss for years,
and they recently released a new app
that uses augmented reality and the golden ratio
to find the perfect brow shape for your face.
And the app will also give you a step-by-step guide
on how to achieve that look.
This is why Anastasia is the brow goddess.
And one of those steps probably involves a tweezer.
Okay, this one is my suggestion.
It's my go-to.
It's the Tweezerman Ultra Precision Slant
and there's something about this one, nailed it perfect.
It really grabs.
You know when you do that tweezer thing and you're like,
"I can't get the hair."
It's so frustrating.
Not with this baby, every single time it is perfection.
Okay, so another tool in my arsenal
is the FLOWER Beauty Micro Pencil
and what I love about this,
is it's so tiny and thin that you can really use it
in like a precision point way.
You can get in those little tiny holes.
This is definitely a go-to for me.
And what I also love about it is that it has
one of those beautiful little brushes,
that's like a pad on the other side,
so you can really shape the brow in a different way.
Another one that I love is our Brow Fix.
Now, I really love a Spoolie with a really nice amount
of product that you can get,
so that you can completely shape the brow,
either very arched and beautiful, or in fashion.
One thing that really never goes out of style
or is always on trend, is that kind of
crazy, waxy, soapy, brow where all the hairs are dispersed.
So you can do that really easily with this product.
And that is sort of the cooler more runway approach.
And you can do that with this too.
So you can have the jaggedy, more editorial eye,
or something very croft and refined with this one product.
I am obsessed, it is my go-to for brows,
depending on what brow I'm looking to achieve that day.
So we bowed down to the brows and their powers
to transform our faces and make sure to show them
the love that they deserve and we'll raise a brow to that.
(upbeat music)